- Hey everybody.
I just posted an Instagram
post for your phone number.
This is the first
call in #AskGaryVee show!
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Live in LA, even that,
even that I think brings a lot
of value to this
#AskGaryVee show.
Phil's here which is super weird
and I'm damn
pretty excited about it.
DRock always loves new stuff.
Obviously, if you've been paying
attention over last week there's
been a lot of changes in
the social media ecosystem and
I've been tripling
down on an Instagram world.
We've been doing a ton of
things on the 60 Second Club.
DailyVee has gone daily,
(camera snapping)
and that is been quite intense
and a lot of fun and
most of all the Facebook,
excuse me, the Instagram
live feature just posted and we
played a little
bit around with that.
I was sneaky on this one, right?
I was trying to be sneaky.
And there's been a lot of
pressure internally for me of
not doing The #AskGaryVee Show
and I think one of the things
that is important
is always evolving and
Ty you can start
dialing right now.
I think what's really exciting
is that we are now going to a
call in show format
for #AskGaryVee so,
go ahead, go ahead,
do your thing,
and so all I'll need is for
you to tell me the phone number.
You can go louder, don't worry.
What's that?
- [Phil] (laughs)
Is that a fax number?
- That's not what you do.
You do this.
There you go.
Just teaching
Tyler how to use a phone.
And so what we're going to
be doing now is we're gonna be
posting for your
phone number on Instagram.
If you're not following
me on Instagram (bell dings).
It's alright, you gotta
get through the kinks.
One (phone dialing), alright.
Anyway, we'll see how
long it takes Tyler to post a
phone number but
we're posting on Instagram,
your phone numbers go in there.
We call, you come and ask for a
question and we do it just like
a live call in radio show.
Same thing as you would be doing
if you were posting but here
with a little bit feedback.
(phone ringing)
Here we go,
what's the name?
- [Tyler] Anton.
- Anton?
And here we go, folks.
(phone ringing)
- [Anton] What's up?
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk,
how are you?
- [Anton] I'm great, Gary.
How are you?
- I'm doing good, Anton.
You are the first caller on
The #AskGaryVee
Show live call in show.
How do you feel about that?
- [Anton] Oh, that's awesome.
I was just thinking about you,
what I want to ask but first of
all, I just wanted to
tell you that there is a great
opportunity for you
and for your company.
There's a Russian businessman in
Russia who has the first digital
bank in Moscow and he has
$150K competition for
a digital marketing company
who will make an ad
for him. So, I just thought--
- Anton, I don't get out
of bed for at least $151,000.
(Anton and Gary laugh)
I'll take a look.
You can send me an email
on that but for the show,
I got to keep it tight.
this is a good
framework for everybody.
Obviously, everybody's
gonna want to say their things.
For keeping it tight,
we'll go into the question.
What question can
I answer for you, brother?
- [Anton] I just wanted to
ask you what do you think is the
most critical thing
for people who
come out of military?
You know trying to trans--
- Yes.
Yes, thats a
great question, Anton.
Thank you so much for that.
I'll do this.
That's how we got to do it.
We got to do it like that.
Like the call in radio shows.
- [Tyler] Right.
- Anton, great question.
Yeah, this way but
I might want to keep it.
I'll make those decisions.
Anton, I think when a
transition from military to the
private sector you gotta
readjust to the new framework.
So many people struggle with
transition from whether it's the
education system,
the military system,
the government system into the
private sector
where the market controls.
Where we have bureaucracies
and these big machines,
they're not always
playing by market dynamics.
So the biggest transition is
understanding the market is in
control not your general,
not your general's general,
not your boss's boss,
not the bureaucrats,
not the politicians, no, no.
The market and so to me when
you go into the private sector
understanding that,
now obviously within an
organizational or corporation
which is more similar
to those dynamics you'll
play those politics but if you
go into entrepreneurship,
that's a whole different game.
The market gets to decide
and understanding that the way
you've had it before is not the
way you're gonna have it forward
is extremely important.
You gotta be prepared
for that market dynamic.
Way too many people getting
punched in the face by the
market, go ahead, and not being
able to adjust and so I think
that to me is what stands out
as the biggest vulnerability of
people transitioning
from the military.
Very structured system,
one that they go through this,
the scales of the organization
and then going into the
private sector especially
entrepreneurship it is a
wild, wild west opportunity.
Who we talking about here?
(phone ringing)
- [Tyler] Ren Sim.
- Ren.
(phone ringing)
#AskGaryVee call in show.
- [Ren] Hello?
- Ren?
- [Ren] Gary?
- Yes, this Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Ren] Dude, no way.
This is so crazy.
- (laughs) Welcome
to The #AskGaryVee show.
What can I answer for you?
- [Ren] Wow, I didn't think
I was gonna get the phone call.
- Ren, Ren, the point of this
was I'm putting out the numbers,
it's for The #AskGaryVee show,
you gotta have your
question ready, baby.
- [Ren] I know,
I know. It's okay.
Let's see how
well I do on the spot.
- I like it. Why
don't we do this,
while I buy you some time.
Ren, where are you from?
- [Ren] Originally,
I'm from Estonia.
- Very nice.
- [Ren] I live in
Seattle, Washington right now.
- Very nice.
Big day for Seattle here.
Obviously, the big contest
winner who's gonna shadow me
for the day was from Seattle.
Ren, what question
can I answer for you?
- [Ren] Alright, so
almost 21 years old.
I'm going to school even though
I know I should just be doing
business or
becoming an entrepreneur,
how do I, what do you think,
just finish school and do it or
what do you think?
- Well, let's break it down.
Why are you staying in school?
Are you doing it
for your parents,
are you doing it for yourself or
do you still have some thoughts
that an education
is a good backup plan?
What's your truth?
Don't bullshit me, Ren.
- [Ren] Honestly,
self doubt and that's it.
- I love you for that.
I love you so
much, Ren, for that.
So now the question
becomes why do you have that?
What do you have in your
history that creates that?
Have you been able, the one
thing that allows kids to make
the jump if they have self doubt
is if they have a
history of making money.
What allowed me to never be
scared was I knew
I could make a dime.
Have you have selling or
entrepreneurial background
as a teenager, as a kid?
Have you ever made
money selling shit?
- [Ren] Oh yeah, Gary.
I was like in third grade my
friends were playing outside and
my family didn't have
money so I was mowing lawns,
washing cars and
doing all that stuff.
I used to get in trouble in
middle school because I used to
sell candy bars during class.
- Ren, let me
ask you a question.
Are you willing to live in your
parents' home or somewhere else
like real super ghetto
basement with seven friends?
Do you need to be fancy 'cause
you want to hook up and play
that part or if it's burning
you inside and you're willing to
live very humbly and eat shit
food for a while and not have
fancy things and just work on
your business then
you can make that jump.
That's really
what it comes down to.
- [Ren] Mhmmm.
Yeah, I know a lot of people
say that they would but I know
myself and I would be fine.
When I went to my year
in college I was debating on
sleeping in my car just to save
tuition money so
I could open something up.
- Listen, Ren,
to be very honest,
just even going through this
talk I think you win either way.
If you want to take
these next couple years,
work out your doubt issues and
maybe get into
a place where you can--
Phil can you answer that
question 'cause I got
Tyler tied up in the show.
If you want to work out those
issues and get into a place
where you have some fun and not
have that responsibility and you
want to go out and party
and things of that nature,
I think that's super fine.
But I also think asking you
those questions
I think you're in a place.
You can't tell them,
I need 15 minutes.
Let them know.
I think you're also in a place
where you'll be okay
if you make that jump.
I think you're in a
good spot either way,
I like your vibe.
- [Ren] Alright, man.
Thank you so much.
- Alright, take care.
- [Ren] Hey Gary, I know you
probably got to go but one day
I'm gonna meet you
man have a lunch with you.
I don't know how or
when but it's gonna happen.
- I hope so Ren.
Good luck to you, man.
Thanks.
- [Ren] Alright, man, thank you.
- Alright, Ren.
Keep going, keep going.
(dial tone) You can
lower that a little bit.
Actually, it's fine.
This is gonna be fun.
I think this brings a
totally different dynamic.
It gives extra layers
of context to the show.
I'm really enjoying,
you got to keep
breaking things, DRock.
Look at this, DailyVee and
#AskGaryVee going into 2017,
both format changes.
(phone ringing)
- [Tyler] Julie Rivera.
- Julie.
Totally different
format changes.
Two format changes
going into 2017.
This is eating my own dog food.
You've got to put
yourself out of business.
I have two successful shows and
I'm breaking them
to make them better.
I love it and I can go back
if this format doesn't work.
I can go back.
Ooh, Julie's gonna lose here.
Julie Ramirez.
- [Tyler] Julie?
- Hold on.
Leave this.
No, no, leave this.
This is my favorite part.
- [Miguel] Hello,
you've reached Miguel--
- That doesn't sound like Julie.
(group laughter)
- Alright, next.
(dog barking)
Oh wow.
- [Tyler] Interesting.
- [Gary] There's some dog
action going on out there.
I like it.
Let's go.
Let's go, Ty.
You need to be quicker on the
trigger while I try to create no
silence space here.
DailyVee yesterday to Atlanta.
Should definitely
check that out.
Subscribe to
Instagram notifications.
If you have not done that, I'm
telling you you're gonna miss
out on a ton of
stuff in my world.
(phone ringing)
What do you got here?
- [Tyler] Sammy.
- Sammy?
Alright, let's see what Sammy's
question is gonna be on
The #AskGaryVee Show
Live call in show.
- [Sammy] Hello?
- Sammy?
- [Sammy] Hey, what's up?
- It's GaryVee.
- [Sammy] Gary,
this is awesome, bro.
- And you are on the show.
- [Sammy] That is incredible.
I got a question for you.
- Let's go.
Go right into it, Sammy.
- [Sammy] Hey man, my question
is have you ever had to make a
business decision that might
mess up a friendship or--
- Yep!
- if you were
partners with someone--
- Yep!
- and how did you
deal with that, man?
- Yep, so I've
had a lot of them.
I was in business with my dad
and I knew that I wanted to do
other things and that was insane
of the thought of leaving that.
My friend Charles Pearson
was one of my best friends when
I was running my business
and I had to fire him and
he was one of
my best social friends.
I had to fire him because he
wasn't bringing it and he was
doing things that were taking
advantage of our friendship and
he didn't think
I was a meritocracist.
VaynerMedia currently
has a lot of family member.
I had both my
brother-in-laws now involved.
I have tons of AJ's friends,
all of them are
being treated differently.
If you are unable to
treat business for business,
your business will die.
And so, that's okay because some
times you may want to pick your
friendship over that
business and that's fine.
But yes, I've been in a lot
of those situations and I think
that, especially
with friendships,
you're gonna either create
cancer from the situation or
you're gonna fix the situation.
You have to understand,
if there's
friction from your end,
it's already a lost situation.
Either you're gonna fire and
you're gonna have to deal with
that person or break up or
whatever you're talking about
and that person's effected by
it or you're gonna eat shit and
it's gonna turn into a cancer
cell internally in the business
and yourself and eventually it's
gonna reap it's head and you're
gonna have an issue. Got it?
So, you've already lost.
You might as well get the bad
part over with quickly so that
the business can
survive that loss.
- [Sammy] That's exactly
what I needed to hear, Gary.
Thanks so much.
- You got it.
Take care.
This is gonna be a good show.
(dial tone) This is
gonna be a good show, Phil.
This is gonna be a good show.
- [Phil] 'Cause I'm here.
- Do you think, you may
have to be in every episode.
- [Phil] Think so.
- [Gary] Talking about
your venture capital love.
(Phil laughs)
Who's this?
(phone ringing)
- [Tyler] This is Levi Rains.
- Levi.
(phone ringing)
This is so fun.
- [Levi] Gary-fuckin'-Vee.
(group laughter)
- Levi, you are on the show.
- [Levi] Oh man, that's crazy.
Okay, I need to tell
you something real quick.
- Go ahead. Real fast.
- [Levi] Yeah, I'll be quick.
So I was on the Instagram Live,
I didn't even know you could do
that but the craziest thing
about that just think about how
insane it is that you can put
a camera to your face and show
someone else
where you're at live.
That's crazy to me.
- I totally agree, man.
I think people are
underestimating the
technology revolution.
Going live to thousands of
people was something that cost
millions of dollars and only
a few people could do just
a decade and a half ago
and so it's incredible,
it leads to stuff like this.
I mean look
what's going on here.
All of this is
so interconnected.
I went live, then a
meeting got canceled.
Then I'm like, "Hey, DRock,
"let's go do
The #AskGaryVee Show,"
then I post on
Instagram phone numbers,
then we call you and
now Levi you're on the show.
- [Levi] Hell yeah,
that's crazy.
I watched like a whole 50
minutes of you calling people
and I don't know why but
it was really entertaining.
- [Mikhail] Hi, this is Mikhail.
- Mikhail, this
is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Mikhail] Goddammit, Gary!
(group laughter)
- [Levi] A lot of good
info in there too but--
- I appreciate it.
Awesome.
- [Levi] Thanks
for all the stuff.
I'm reading Jab, Jab,
Right Hook right now.
Excited.
- Thank you.
- [Levi] Thanks, man.
- What's your question, brother?
- [Levi] My question, okay, so
I have a career but my career
I get four days on and four days
off and what I want to do as
a side thing is market,
we have restaurants
around where I live
in the Portland area that don't
even have a Facebook page and
that's crazy to me because it's
just old people
running their restaurant.
- Yep.
- [Levi] I feel like if they
would give me a chance to go on
their Facebook,
go on their Instagram--
- Let me give you, Levi,
let me give you a
great piece of advice.
Do it for free at first,
have five clients and then you
can use them to
show other people.
The amount of people that are
not willing to do stuff for free
at first to create case studies.
Phil Toronto in this room
right now is my right hand man
in all my investments.
What did he do?
He interned for
free for a long time.
DRock made a free film.
Made a free film and
now he's DRock. Right?
Tyler, well Tyler, but anyway.
(group laughter)
Levi, you've
gotta go free on this.
Go and do two, when you're
doing whatever you're doing,
whoever you like the most when
you're in their restaurants you
like the couple,
you think they're sweet
offer to do the
services for free.
They become your case studies
then you charge $100 a month,
then you charge $500 a month,
then you build a business.
People aren't willing to eat
shit in a 2017 world and that's
why so many people's
businesses haven't started.
- [Levi] Awesome,
that's great advice.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm just gonna
go out and look--
- Keep me updated.
Call back in in a month.
Keep me updated.
Love you, see ya.
I like Levi.
(dial tone)
This is fun.
(phone dialing)
What do we got, Ty?
Sorry, by the way this
is just for the episode,
my sister just texted me.
I'm just going to say I love
her while I wait for this.
- [Automated Voice] Your
call has been forwarded to an
automatic voice--
- Ugh, tough luck.
Let's go.
(Phil laughs)
Let's go, Ty.
- [Tyler] Alright.
- You got to be way faster, Ty.
You got to be way faster.
You know?
Got to get more Levi's on there.
Sorry just got distracted
had to say what's up to my sis.
She's doing great.
A big shout out
to Max and Hannah,
my niece and nephew,
on my sis's side.
(phone ringing)
- [Tyler] Dustin Riddle.
- Dustin Riddle.
- Zach and Dylan
on the other side.
- [Dustin] Hello?
- Dustin!
- [Dustin] Yes.
- This is GaryVee
and you're on the show.
- [Dustin] Oh my God.
(group laughter)
- What is your question?
- [Dustin] You know what?
I don't have a question.
What I want to say is this.
- Go ahead.
- [Dustin] I've been following
you for probably three years now
and I can't tell you how many
times I got emotional
watching you post.
You are so down to Earth.
You're just the most with
it dude that I have ever come
across and I look up
to you like no other.
- I really appreciate that.
- [Dustin] I just want
to say thank you.
- Thank you so much, brother.
- [Dustin] That's it.
- I appreciate you.
- [Dustin] If I ever get the
opportunity to shadow you ever,
work for you,
whatever it may be,
I will do it without question.
- Well, I have great news.
Once a quarter, four times
a year on the 60 Second Club
I'm gonna give away the shadow
so look out for that, okay?
- [Dustin] Thank
you very much, Gary.
- You got it brother.
Love you, pal.
Thank you for that.
That meant a lot to me.
- [Dustin] Love you, too.
(dial tone)
- Alright, listen we
need to establish the
rules for the call in show now.
We have a real connection
and I feed off your feedback
and love and you guys know that.
You're starting
to figure me out.
I live for that feedback,
for that engagement,
for the love. I do.
I got mine, I don't need you.
I don't need your courses.
I don't need you buying
my books to be very frank.
I really, really don't.
I've got my advances up front.
I really don't.
What I need is the community and
so some of you are figuring that
out and that's why
phone calls like that happen.
And so, I appreciate it but, we
can do that at different times.
We'll do random call-ins but
when we do The #AskGaryVee Show
if you're gonna put your
number in Instagram,--
- [Automated Voice] Please
leave your message for--
- if you're gonna leave your
phone number in the comments
you're gonna have to have
a question because I think,
I want to do right by.
I can, listen, I feed
off of just all day long.
(dial tone)
Ty, pick a fucking number.
- I'm doing something here.
- [Gary] What are you doing?
What you're doing is breaking
the show is what you're doing.
(laughs) I'm doing
something here.
(group laughter)
I mean, we need one more.
- [Tyler] I know,
I'm working on it.
- [Gary] Jeez, we're gonna
clearly have to
bring India back.
(DRock laughs)
(dial tone)
So ground rules for
this new call in show,
you've got to have a question.
I'll take the love, we'll
intermix it but I really want to
bring value to the community and
really a great thing that the
Vayner Nation can do is
think about questions that are
uniquely for everybody
too or frame them in that way.
Who's this?
(phone ringing)
- [Tyler] This is Gio Soto.
- Gio.
Are you going international?
- [Tyler] No.
- Try an international one.
- [Tyler] Okay.
- We'll do a whole
international show.
We got to
intermix international.
Come on, Gio.
- [Automated Voice] You have
reached the voicemail box--
(DRock groans)
- Don't do that,
I wanted the name.
DRock, you're not in
control of the phone.
I know you get,
I've watched you roll.
Let's go, Ty, real fast.
I've watched you roll
for the last year or two.
You like getting your
hands in a lot of places.
I love that about you.
You're a full pledged Swiss Army
knife but if you ever hang up on
the phone again, I'm gonna
rip your fingers off 'cause
I desperately wanted to
see if it was gonna say Gio.
If it would've started with a
number I would
have turned it off.
Just to give you a little tell.
(phone ringing)
This is mine, that is yours.
(DRock chuckles)
I don't touch your camera.
Who's this?
- [Tyler] The Originator.
- [Andrew] Hello?
- Originator, this is GaryVee
and you're on the show.
- [Andrew] Are you serious?
- I'm dead serious.
- [Andrew] I literally put
my number down thinking out of
those 2,000 comments this
was gonna be another number.
- Well, guess what?
It's not and you've got
your shot to ask me a question.
What do you got, my man?
- [Andrew] Wow, I actually
just forgot the question.
- (laughs) Well, let's do this.
I'll buy you a second.
What do you do for a living
or what's your life up to?
- [Andrew] I literally
just graduated from college,
oh, I remember.
I literally just graduated
from college two days ago with a
business management degree.
- Well, congratulations my man.
What's your question?
- [Andrew] So, I applied to
a lot of places and I actually
tried to apply to VaynerMedia.
- Yep.
- [Andrew] But I was trying
to figure out how do I get
experience if a
lot of companies
are asking for experience.
- I think one of the, you know
and this is the advice
and the theme of the show.
I got to tell you man, I don't
think it's a bad idea to work
for free or an internship or, or
get a job and at night from 7--
Let's work backwards,
what do you want to do?
What did you apply
for at VaynerMedia?
The ACC role,
that entry level role?
- [Andrew] Yeah, well I was
looking at some internships.
I want to do media.
Media analyst.
- Okay, so here's
what I would say.
Where do you live?
- [Andrew] In
Richmond, Virginia.
- I love it.
So everybody watching in
The #AskGaryVee Show if you
have a company that needs media
analysts please leave a comment
below in YouTube or Facebook
so he can check that out.
But number two, listen
to me and listen to me good.
Reach out to 50 to 100
businesses in the
Richmond, Virginia
area that have
those roles or
needs and tell them
that you're willing to intern
for free or work after-hours in
it or look for startups
'cause there's ton in the
Richmond, Virginia area,
tons of startups will take
your 7 P.M. to 10 P.M.
hustle so you get a job that
pays the bills and pay your
student loans or
whatever you've got.
I've got to be empathetic to the
practicality but then you go and
switch from 7 P.M. to
10 at night and you go work
for free at a startup and that
becomes the experience
that you use to get a job
in what you want to do.
My man, what's your first name?
- [Andrew] Andrew.
- Andrew, my man, listen to me.
The biggest problem with a lot
of players that are young today
is they're fancy.
They're not willing to
back up their ambition.
So, if you want this, if
you want to be a media analyst,
if you want to
control your narrative,
if you can't get
a job by applying,
then you've got to go to plan B.
And plan B is to go work at a
startup for free
from 7 to 10 P.M.
so you build your resume and if
you crush it there and you're so
great, they'll probably offer
you a full-time job. Got it?
- [Andrew] Alright,
I really appreciate it.
I just literally just got put
on to you like two weeks ago and
I've watched so much content.
My brother just put me on.
I'm putting my friends on,
I'm telling everybody to watch
DailyVee every single day.
- I appreciate it, my man.
- [Andrew] I appreciate
that you called me.
- I love it, man.
I wish you well. Take care.
I think that's good.
- [Tyler] One more?
- You want to sneak one more in?
Alright, go real fast.
You've got one,
you're feeling good?
- [Tyler] Yep.
(dial tone)
- One of my favorite Jets of
all time just asked me if I was
available on text so
Tyler really upset me.
This better be good, Ty.
- [Tyler] This is...
- I love that man.
- [Tyler] Angelica.
- Angelica.
International? Nope.
- [Tyler] No, she's national.
- Okay.
- [Phil] (laughs) National.
(laughs) National.
(group laughter)
(phone ringing)
- [Angelica] Hello?
- Angelica?
- [Angelica] Shut the fuck, yes?
- This is GaryVee
and you are on the show.
- [Angelica] You have got to be
frickin' kidding
me right this second.
- I am not kidding.
- [Angelica] Oh my God.
- (laughs) Do you
have a question?
- [Angelica] You know,
honestly, I've just been
trying to hit you up
because I wanted to thank you.
I got so many things
in my brain right now.
We're starting up our new
social business
coaching company.
I don't really have a question
because I honestly did not think
you would call me and
I'm freaking out right now.
- (laughs) Come on, let's
manufacture one for the show.
Come up with
something even if it's basic.
- [Angelica] Okay, honestly,
you've given me
so much motivation.
I have zero, I mean we're
starting off with nothing.
You know?
- That's good.
- [Angelica] I'm
going just locally.
Right now, what I do for a
company in
Houston is I do their,
I'm like freaking out.
(Gary laughs)
I do their Facebook, answering--
- Yep, yep.
You're doing
community management
for local businesses in Houston.
- [Angelica] Right but
I'm actually in Dallas.
So what I want to do, what we're
doing is we're creating our own
company and
we're gonna go locally.
I've already got a couple of
clients that I'm gonna talk to
and I'm just going to basically
one by one try to
build this clientele.
- So here's, let me
give you some advice.
Couple things.
When you don't have lots
of funding or money and you're
starting at zero,
you've got time.
Your asset and so many people
listening right now that want to
do what they want
to do, they have time.
Time is their currency
and your hustle. Right?
- [Angelica] Right.
- So you watch a
little less GaryVee,
you watch a little less Netflix,
you watch a little
less Dallas Cowboys.
You do a little bit less yoga or
whatever the hell your life is
about and what you do is you go
and ask for business but if you
get a bunch of no's you convert
very quickly in doing one or two
or three pro bono.
Pick ones, do the work for free
but pick ones that are big and
will give you exposure and you
giving free work will give you
leverage of the logo
getting you other work.
Got it?
- [Angelica] Right.
Right, that's perfect.
That's exactly our first
client that's what we're doing.
- Love it.
- [Angelica] We're
not asking for a thing.
We're just asking for
basically, you know,--
- Word of mouth.
Yep, a logo.
You got it.
- [Angelica] and to
get it going.
- Well then you
are well on your way.
Congrats. Go ahead.
- [Angelica] (inaudible) to you.
Basically I'm 24/7 GaryVee.
(group laughter)
- Well, I appreciate it.
Make it 23/7 GaryVee.
I love it.
Have a great holiday.
- [Angelica] You
too and thank you.
- Alright, bye-bye.
And that's it.
The first episode of
The #AskGaryVee Show
live call in episodes.
I think this is
the format for me.
I like it.
There's more of that
improv thing going on.
India, Dunk, your gooses are
cooked and the question of the
day is how would you like
to see this format get better?
What did we do in
the first episode,
how do we make it better?
Vayner Nation take over.
Share it up because the
more shares in the Facebook
environment the
more my juices get going.
I'm pretty funny that way.
You keep asking
questions on the phone
and I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)